nuevamente irlanda del norte motivo del
conflicto entre el reino unido y la
unión europea en esta ocasión por las
vacunas contra el cob y en las últimas
horas bruselas reverso su decisión de
suspender temporalmente una parte del
acuerdo break seal imponiendo controles
para evitar que las vacunas
manufacturadas en su territorio ingresen
al reino unido a través de irlanda del
norte por supuesto esto generó furia en
londres dublín y belfast
la ministra principal de irlanda del
norte arlín foster dijo que era un acto
de increíble hostilidad por parte de la
unión europea y que en este caso lo que
se trata es de salvar vidas luego vino
una conversación entre el primer
ministro boris johnson y la presidenta
de la comisión europea
úrsula von der layen que calmó
temporalmente las aguas pero lo cierto
es que en este creciente conflicto por
las vacunas en europa la unión europea
mantiene su derecho de bloquear de
evitar la exportación de las vacunas
manufacturadas en en su territorio a
terceros países esto pone en riesgo al
parecer creen aquí en londres que las
vacunas compradas
el gobierno británico a facer pueden
estar en peligro de no llegar dado que
estas vacunas son elaboradas en bélgica